das gute an fehlern ist dass man aus
ihnen lernen kann auch aus der
traumtänzerei in sachen
energieversorgung aber jetzt geht es
erstmal ans eingemachte sprich den
geldbeutel und das tut weh also muss die
politik schmerzstillend eingreifen damit
niemand in dunkelheit und kälte landet
sorgen vor dem winter wer wird wie
entlastet jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
wir brauchen ein wuchtiges paket für
entlastungen in der ganzen breite der
gesellschaft daran wird ja auch
gearbeitet
wuchtig das klingt nach bazooka aber auf
diesen begriff hat ja ein anderes
mitglied der ampelkoalition das
copyright und damit herzlich willkommen
bei uns meine gäste im studio berliner
band ist bei uns die präsidentin des
sozialverbandes vdk in deutschland
professor michael eilfort ist vorstand
der stiftung marktwirtschaft
main click above
reporter der wirtschaftswoche ist hier
und ebenso thomas d war sie sind armuts
beauftragt der des evangelischen
kirchenkreises hier in berlin neukölln
bentele das neue entlastungspaket sollen
maßgeschneidert effizient und zielgenau
sein das sagt der bundeskanzler trifft
das eigentlich auch auf die bisherigen
zwei pakete zu die wir schon von der
bundesregierung verpasst bekommen haben
also wenn der bundeskanzler mit seiner
regierung all diese maßgaben die er
selber gemacht hat erfüllt dann freue
ich mich sehr bei den letzten
entlassungs paketen habe ich schon
einiges vermisst zum beispiel kennen sie
ja die vdk kritik rentnerin renten haben
keine energiepreis pauschale bekommen
der tank rabatt ist oft versickert oder
hat vor allem auch menschen mit einem
dicken suv und 200 auf der autobahn
entlastet finde ich natürlich nicht so
super und hätte gerne dass vor allem
menschen entlastet werden die es
wirklich brauchen
und da habe ich jetzt große hoffnung
dass die bundesregierung liefert gut das
werden wir noch genau angucken was da
geplant ist und das auch sinnvoll ist er
ein wort welche entlastungsmaßnahmen
sind denn eigentlich angesichts der
notlage vieler menschen und auch vieler
unternehmen sind voll vor allem vor
allem gezielte also keine gießkanne kein
land weltweit hat so viel in der korona
pandemie für seine bevölkerung auch für
die unternehmen getan zur entlastung
insofern ist das schon viel passiert wir
haben schon zwei pakete hinter uns und
wir müssen jetzt eher bisschen die
kirche im dorf lassen also gezielt die
wirklich bedürftigen zu erreichen ist
das eine da bin ich mit frau bentele
noch ein ich nicht damit ein ich bin ich
mit die rentnerinnen und rentner müssen
denn die rentner sind die best versorgte
bevor als gruppe haben in den letzten
jahren weit über inflation
rentenerhöhungen bekommen haben die
größten wohlstands zuwächse der letzten
30 jahre geerntet in deutschland
insofern auch bei rentnern ganz
besonders gezielt da gibt es auch eine
grundsicherung im alter aber bitte nicht
mit der gießkanne
also das heißt die die niedrige renten
bekommen hatte war sie sind ich habe
schon gesagt als beauftragter der
evangelischen kirche hier in berlin
neukölln das ist ja ein problem
stadtteil ein problembezirk
sie haben ja die folgen der massiven
inflation 79 prozent jetzt gegen wurde
im august des letzten jahres tagtäglich
vor augen wie machen sich denn konkret
in ihrer alltagspraxis diese doch zum
teil massiv gestiegenen preise bemerkbar
das macht sich bemerkbar in dem sinne
dass unsere sozialeinrichtung darunter
leiden müssen das heißt also dass das
budget nicht mehr übereinstimmt mit der
bahre haften was wir ausgeben was wir an
menschen betreuen das funktioniert nicht
mehr die klientel der obdachlosen
wohnungslosen verdoppelt sich und das
spüren die einrichtung massiv und das
budget geht aber nicht mit es wird nicht
erhöht und das fehlt mir auch in den
entlastungs paket das fehlt mir das
stimmt und ich weiß nicht ob das im
dritten entlastungspaket zu stattfinden
wird das glaube ich nicht also ich bin
da sehr gespannt der
bundeskanzler oder unserer
bundesfinanzminister sich da noch mal
bewegt und die trägerschaft auch stützt
denn gerade diese diese gruppe hat man
komplett vergessen daniel goffart was
kann denn die bundesregierung eigentlich
tun um diese massive inflation zu
stoppen geht hier eigentlich klug vor
hat sich das schon planen also plant sie
nicht es gab ja diese idee der
konzertierten aktion nach dem
historischen vorbild dass man also so
die ursprungsidee arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer mal zusammenführt und sagt
lass uns mal über die nächste lohnrunde
reden man versucht vielleicht mit
einmalzahlung mit länger an
tarifverträgen das alles ein bisschen zu
strecken warum damit man nicht so eine
sogenannte lohn-preis-spirale hat also
das sozusagen die die gewerkschaften
verlangen dass die gestiegenen preise
sich dann wieder finden steigenden
löhnen und steigender löhne wenn wieder
zu steigenden preisen man kommt dann so
ein spiralbewegung brand und das soll
versucht werden zu durchbrechen das
problem seit ich mit den flaschen jetzt
schon so hoch ist kann man
wahrscheinlich von den tarifparteien zum
surfen arbeitnehmerseite kaum verlangen
dass sie die füße stillhalten insofern
bin ich gespannt was er wirklich bei
auskommen jetzt ist das ja nicht das
erste mal dass die ampel koalition weil
sie eben auch eine ampel ist mit
unterschiedlichen farben auch ganz
unterschiedliche signale sendet jetzt
nämlich mal das
oder nehmen sie mal beim wort mit den
beiden begriffen die sie da heute von
sich gegeben hat zielgenau sagt der
bundeskanzler wuchtig sagt der
bundesfinanzminister dass eine scheint
das gegenteil vom anderen zu sein soll
es also nur für die besonders
betroffenen seien weil möglicherweise
gar nicht so viel geld da ist oder
sollen möglichst viele davon profitieren
damit eben ja bis weit in die
mittelschicht hinein auch die leute da
einigermaßen über die runden kommen wie
geht man mit dieser situation hinzu
es ist natürlich die kritik die herford
eben auch schon geäußert hat berechtigt
dass man hilfen im endeffekt erstmal auf
die bedürftigen konzentrieren sollte
aber das bedeutet ja nicht dass wir
angesichts der enormen steuerlast auch
für die für die mitte der gesellschaft
für die arbeiten der mitte nicht
überlegen müssen wie wir da auch ein
bisschen helfen können also die
inflation sorgt ja nicht nur bei den
unteren einkommensgruppen für probleme
sondern natürlich auch bei den mittleren
und da war ja der vorschlag von
finanzminister lindner dass wir eben
auch eine entlastung im steuerlichen
bereich man um dieses sogenannte kalte
progression auszugleichen ist also
sozusagen die die lohnerhöhung nicht
gleich wieder aufgefressen werden das
ist dann abgelehnt worden von spd und
grünen mit dem argument was ich falsch
finde das eben von einer
steuerentlastung natürliche oberen
einkommen mehr profitieren in der summe
stimmt das prozentual stimmt es nicht
steuern werden erhoben nach
leistungsgerechtigkeit leistungsvermögen
das heißt wer viel verdient muss viele
steuern zahlen aber wenn entlastet
werden soll dann sollen auch alle
entlastet werden das ist der gedanke den
herr lindner da vorgeschlagen hat und
der in der koalition offenbar nicht gut
gelitten ist und ich bin gespannt wie
man da versucht einen kompromiss zu
finden
das nicht aber die schwierigkeit
verbindet das wo zieht man da eigentlich
die grenze sie sind ja eher die
anhängerin einer zielgenauen
unterstützung wir reden auch gleich noch
was das wasser im einzelnen geplant ist
darüber aber wo zieht man da die grenze
wer ist wirklich bedürftig wer hat es
wirklich nötig wo kann man sagen gut das
bedeutet zwar einen gewichtsverlust aber
bei leuten die ein einigermaßen gutes
einkommen haben ist das vielleicht über
einen gewissen zeitraum hin zu ertragen
wo wird da eigentlich die grenze gezogen
wo ist ein ausreichendes einkommen da
und wo ist kein ausreichendes einkommen
dar also erstmal ist das natürlich auch
die große crux bei den letzten end
leistungspaketen gewesen herford hat
mich ja vorher schon sozusagen eine
andere meinung bekundet zu den
rentnerinnen und rentnern die gibt es
tatsächlich nicht aber genauso wenig
gibt es natürlich auch die
erwerbstätigen trotzdem haben alle
erwerbstätigen auch wie hier in der
runde energiepreis pauschale bekommen
kann man sich ja auch fragen ob das so
nötig ist und viele meiner mitglieder im
sozialverband vdk sind eben rentnerinnen
und rentner mit wirklich wenig rente
menschen die vielleicht auch noch
erwerbstätig sind aber wohl nur eine
person erwerbstätig ist wegen
kindererziehung wegen pflege von
angehörigen betreuung von menschen mit
behinderungen ist es bei uns in der
mitgliedschaft wirklich natürlich ein
riesen thema das viele menschen im
moment eine kleine rente haben und nicht
klar kommen vielleicht niedrige löhne
haben und nicht mehr klarkommen mit
miete steigenden heizkosten steigenden
strom- und lebensmittelpreisen und diese
menschen zu entlasten ist natürlich das
wichtigste aber ihre frage wo zieht man
die grenze ist natürlich immer
berechtigt und deswegen war der ansatz
der ampelkoalition die energiepreis
pauschale sehr vielen zu geben mit dem
argument dann trifft man in
anführungsstrichen auch alle mit einer
gießkanne hat damit eben die rentnerin
rentner eben ausgespart was ich als
sozial verbandspräsidentin nicht richtig
finde gerade insbesondere natürlich
jetzt nicht für die renterin rentner die
noch ein paar immobilien besitzen aber
das sind halt auch nicht so viel wie
manche denken viele rentner und rentner
sind jetzt schon von altersarmut bedroht
oder betroffen und haben hat auch keine
chance mehr genau wie kinder jugendliche
aus eigener kraft was in ihrer situation
zu ändern und genau das finde ich muss
auch ein bisschen die maßgabe sein
was haben menschen eben für einen
einkommen und vom vermögen zur verfügung
und da ist schon einer der vorschläge
von herrn lindner den ich gar nicht so
schlecht finde da eben auch mehr
ausgleich über die steuererklärung zu
schaffen also wirklich zu gucken was hat
jemand für ein zu versteuerndes
einkommen was hat jemand für geld zur
verfügung und hier eben wirklich auch
ein austausch herzustellen zwischen den
verschiedenen systemen auch der finanz
den finanzbehörden und zum beispiel eben
der rentenversicherung damit man eben
auch weiß wer hat welches einkommen zur
verfügung und kann dann eben auch sagen
die die wirklich wenig geld haben die
keine möglichkeiten haben durch
erwerbseinkommen ihre situation zu
verbessern die auch alle ihr geld für
den täglichen bedarf ausgeben das sind
ja die menschen im moment die wirklich
am allerstärksten unter den hohen
verbrauchs preisen leiden jemand der ein
bisschen rücklagen hat der findet es
natürlich auch ärgerlich aber für die
menschen ist es immer noch in
irgendeiner weise machbar mir schreiben
leute für die das überhaupt nicht mehr
machbar ist weil die haben einfach
nichts zurückgelegt wurde die wahl jetzt
auch nicht die frage bei den
wohlstandsverlusten wenn kann wenn
jemand kein wohlstand hat allerdings
auch nicht verlieren gibt einen riesen
verteilungskampf auch an bei diesen
entlastungs paketen wenn wir die
haushaltseinnahmen des emirats katar
hätten wäre das alles kein problem dann
könnte man jeden so viel geld geben wir
haben möchte aber das ist ja genau das
problem dass auch die ressourcen des
staates begrenzt sind
die frage ist natürlich auch eine frage
der politischen durchsetzbarkeit in der
koalition wird das noch zu einem ganz
großen problem werden das wird ein
riesen problem und man muss ja auch
ehrlich sagen weil wir jetzt alles über
den über der sendung den titel stehen
haben wer wird wie entlastet die
gegenfrage die dazu kommt ist ja auch
wer wird wie belastet denn immer da wo
entlastung ist es auch belastungen es
gibt entweder steuerausfälle oder es
gibt neue schulden die zukünftige
generation belasten also irgend jemand
zahlt die ganze veranstaltung und
insofern müssen wir uns schon ehrlich
machen damit nicht in der mitte wo die
großen steuereinnahmen und auch die
sozial beitragseinnahmen generiert
werden so viele reiche gibt es gar nicht
sie können die reichensteuer um 10% auf
einschlag anheben und kriegen gerade mal
schlappe 4 milliarden zusammen in
deutschland pro jahr also die masse
macht kasse heißt es die miete zahlt den
start die arbeitende werktätige mitte
zahlt den start und deswegen
ist es falsch zu sagen auch bei der
energie wie das hat frau bentele ja
gesagt da bin ich mir einig bei der bei
dem energie geld das da alle pauschal
was kriegen das ist linke tasche rechte
tasche die mitte zahlst und die mitte
kriegt auch wir lügen uns da was vor es
geht um wirkliche bedürftigkeit auf der
einen seite das auch setzt auch
bürokratische verfahren und prüfungen
und einzelfallprüfungen voraus und auf
der anderen seite geht es aber auch
darum zu sagen leistungsgerechtigkeit es
muss sich schon noch lohnen zu arbeiten
wenn sie immer den mit 60.000 euro im
jahr den familien die schon im
spitzensteuersatz sind die
sozialbeiträge steuern gez-gebühren die
alles zahlen wenn sie denen immer weiter
was wegnehmen und bei den anderen immer
drauf satteln die nicht leisten aus
unterschiedlichen gründen dann wird
irgendwann der unterschied zu gering und
wer anders schon in bestimmten gruppen
dass es sich wirklich nicht mehr lohnt
zu arbeiten und das passiert ja wir
haben in deutschland
1,4 millionen erwerbsfähige arbeitslose
in der grundsicherung und wir haben zwei
millionen offene stellen und jetzt holen
wir allen ernstes werden wir in der
türkei für die flughäfen bei brutto
gehältern von von mir aus 2500 euro
werben wir leute an die nicht deutsch
können und haben hier 1,4 millionen die
deutsch können und man muss ja nicht ein
astronaut und 1000 hochschulabschlüsse
haben um das zu machen also irgendwas
stimmt da was nicht in diesem land
medien leistungsanreizen deswegen müssen
wir bei der umverteilung schon ehrlich
sein und vor allem nichts mit wucht
nicht dies kann es sondern gezielt und
gezielt heißt aus meiner sicht auch wir
müssen auch das nicht als einbahnstraße
sehen die unterstützung solidarität ja
aber es bedingt auch im gegenzug dass
diejenigen zb in der grundsicherung auch
rentner in der grundsicherung die
bekommen eine volle erstattung der
heizkosten dass da auch anreize
entstehen das sich auch da das
energiesparen lohnt wir müssen alle auch
gas und strom einsparen im sinne des
klimaschutzes und da müssen auch anreize
gibt er möglicherweise jetzt eine idee
dass man sagt dass eine mindestmenge die
ihn jemand braucht um im winter
eine warme stube zu haben dass die dasa
der gas- oder überhaupt der energiepreis
gedeckelt wird alles was drüber ist
robert haben oder sein luxus ist eine
möglichkeit gerade bei menschen die
eigentlich ja kaum
möglichkeiten haben zu reagieren auf
solche massiven preissteigerungen ist
das referat das ja auch schon erwähnt
das ist ein grund bedarf an energie gibt
es kann nicht sein dass er energie als
erpressung geld also ich sehe da schon
ein bischen erpresserisch wenn die
energiefirmen immer mehr die kosten hoch
schrauben und die leute gerade die
rentner oder auch im behindertenbereich
das nicht mehr bezahlen können und wenn
die leute anfangen im finstern zu sitzen
das beispiel habe ich ja vorhin schon
gesagt das ist tatsächlich schon so dass
ältere herrschaften die lichter
ausmachen dass sie alles mögliche
versuchen um die energie zu sparen weil
sie überhaupt nicht mehr wissen wie sie
damit zurechtkommen wenn ich eine
rentnerin habe die eben nicht in der
grundsicherung ist die 2 300 euro rente
noch hat das haben wir die fälle und
sehr massiv und viele die fangen an zu
sparen aber da wo es eigentlich nicht
sinnvoll ist sondern es müssen
grundbetrag herausgegeben haben von 1500
kw sie hatten glaube 10.000 gesagt wenn
ich mich erinnere
1500 kw pro person dann ist auch die
sparmaßnahme da weiß ich dann wissen ab
1500 kw muss ich jetzt aufpassen und der
großteil man müsste noch mal ganz
ehrlich sagen der großteils sparte er
auch es ist doch nicht so dass das ganze
volk in saus und braus mit energie lebt
wenn sie die einzelnen haushalte sehen
die sprachen und ich habs gerade im
behindertenbereich weil ich hatte auch
diese einrichtung habe sie müssen ihre
elektroroller aufladen und alles
mögliche was sie brauchen das ist viel
energie da kriegen sie zwar einen
zuschuss von der krankenkasse aber mehr
ist es nicht also ich plädiere dafür
hatte seinen grund betrachten gegeben
wird das gilt für strom das gilt für gas
sind das gilt auch für wasser liege an
ihm
einfach nicht mehr so ich finde ein
bisschen pauschal zu sagen es gibt hier
die einen die gar nichts haben und
irgendwie leistungslose immer mehr geld
kriegen sollen und die anderen denen nur
weggenommen wird das ist mir doch ein
bisschen zu einfach weil wir haben schon
heute natürlich auch viele familien die
eben nicht viel geld verdienen wo wir
gesagt vielleicht nur eine arbeiten kann
wo im moment auch wirklich das geld
extrem knapp ist die schreiben und auch
natürlich würde ich ganz klar sagen auch
die brauchen jetzt wirklich dringend
entlastungen da gibt es ja auch schon
vorschläge wie das wohngeld auszuweiten
aber was wir eben auch wissen dass
unsere beratung ist dass ganz viele
menschen zum beispiel weil sie eben
vielleicht auch schlechte löhne bekommen
haben und es gibt durchaus viele firmen
in deutschland die auch gute gewinne
eingefahren haben große konzerne in den
letzten jahren und trotzdem wurden viele
menschen nicht wahnsinnig super nur
bezahlt das sind dann auf menschen die
im alter nicht viel geld haben natürlich
vielleicht auch keine kinderbetreuung da
war dann haben die frauen nicht viel
gearbeitet müssen jetzt theoretisch
grundsicherung alter beantragen machen
es aber nicht weil sie das beschämend
finden wir haben ganz viele menschen die
wirklich auf solche geschichten haben
und denen nur zu sagen wir können nicht
immer nur drauf satteln ist momente da
habe ich jetzt aber halt anders
verstanden dass es ging jetzt nicht und
die
all das
regent empfänger
aber ich würde gerne noch mal nicht sich
einfach einen ganzen koffer die eine
frage das war jetzt hier auch steht ja
der vorwurf nicht nur von verbänden und
von herrn die wir hier im
raum sondern überhaupt dass sich manche
unternehmen eine goldene nase verdienen
gerade im energiebereich
müsste diesen vorschlag gibt es ja auch
häufiger da der staat nicht sehr viel
stärker eingreifen regulieren
möglicherweise bis hin zu einer
staatsbeteiligung oder zur
teilverstaatlichung denn es handelt sich
jetzt nicht um irgendwelche produkte die
jemand auf dem freien markt herstellen
sondern das ist daseinsvorsorge ist da
nichts gibt jetzt die frage der
schlichtung strom gas markt auch eine
komplizierte sache dauert wahrscheinlich
noch dort sollen aber ist da nicht auch
ein muss da nicht der der staat noch
sehr viel stärker eingreifen einer
notsituation in der wir sind ja gute
stadt hat ja wenn wir die letzten krisen
sehen zum beispiel angriffen damals bei
den banken also als die finanzkrise
kamen dann hat er die commerzbank
sozusagen teilverstaatlicht das war kein
gutes geschäft weil die aktien
commerzbank sind heute immer noch nicht
so wertvoll dass man den einsatz in der
stadt gezahlt hat herausbekommen der
lufthansa was anders das verein gegangen
die lufthansa die staatshilfe
zurückgezahlt für den staat
massengeschäft
bei den stromunternehmen wird ja auch
der versuch unternommen eben bei juniper
wissen dass damit die gasversorgung
nicht zusammenbricht weil dieses doch
sehr wichtige unternehmen für die
energieversorgung in deutschland dann in
den konkurs gehen würde wenn man nicht
an kraft bei juniper wird ja auch
angegriffen mit milliardensummen ich bin
aber sehr skeptisch mit mir die meisten
ökonomen was staatliche markt angriffe
anbelangt also bisher funktionierte die
notfallmanager notlagen ja gut aber auch
da muss man sich mal gucken jeder
angriff natürlich und welche folgen und
das auch habeck der glaube ich sonst
nicht so zimperlich ist jetzt mache sehr
vorsichtig ist bei der frage einer gas
deckelung die eben diskutiert wird wie
bei anderen eingriffen zeigt auch ein
bisschen die crux geschichte wenn wir
den gaspreis deckeln irgendwo muss ja
das was über dem deckel liegt
irgendjemand bezahlen und damit sind wir
wieder beim steuerzahler wie bei
staatlichen mechanismen und ob das dann
viel gerechter wird ob das viel
unkomplizierter wird ob das viel
zielgenauer ist da habe ich mal so meine
zweifel und ich bin nicht der einzige
der
da noch einen sidekick machen
die privathaushalte die menschen die
möglicherweise unter massiven
finanziellen druck kommen es gibt aber
auch unternehmen die spanier auch
spanien nicht nur privathaushalte
spanier auch und gezwungenermaßen
sondern auch unternehmen bis hin zu
produktionsrückgang oder
produktionsstillstand was muss denn wenn
das ich jetzt mal vergleichen mit den
bedürfnissen von menschen die nicht
genügend geld haben was müssen den
unternehmen damit sie über die runden
kommen vom staat erwarten können was ist
ja auch dann ja auch beträge die nicht
gerade klein sind kann man das
vergleichen oder ist das spiel das auf
dem anderen terrain unternehmen brauchen
glaube ich vor allem eine gewisse
planungssicherheit und unternehmen
machen dann schon selber auch nötige
umschichtungen in dem einen oder anderen
fall ist vielleicht auch beim bereich
daseinsvorsorge eine hilfe nötig bei der
lufthansa hat auch funktioniert da ist
das geld auch wieder da
unternehmen schichten um und menschen
schichten auch um und man muss ja bei
aller aufregung wir neigen jetzt ein
bisschen auch zu aktionismus also es ist
da die inflation bei den
lebensmittelpreisen und beim treibstoff
sie ist bei den energiepreisen ja noch
gar nicht so angekommen bei den leuten
da kommt also die sorge dann im winter
aber sie ist jetzt da zum beispiel bei
den lebensmitteln vor 60 jahren hat eine
deutsche durchschnittsfamilie
38 prozent ihrer ausgaben im bereich der
lebensmittel ausgeben müssen um sich zu
ernähren
1970 waren es 25 prozent 2020 waren es
15 prozent lebensmittel sind günstiger
geworden so jetzt sind sie wieder ein
bisschen teurer benzin und treibstoff
war vor zehn jahren schon einmal ähnlich
teuer wie heute verglichen am
nettoeinkommen am verfügbaren also jetzt
kommt beides zusammen das ist nun alles
andere als schön und ich sehe auch die
notlagen und ich sehe auch die
einzelfälle die die erreichen uns
genauso unterschreiben da leute aber
nichtsdestotrotz wir müssen ein bisschen
aus dem panik modus raus wir haben jetzt
in deutschland 15 jahre gehabt wo bei
den rentnern die renten wie bei den
arbeitnehmern die löhne real gewachsen
sind über dem inflationsniveau in den
letzten jahren besonders stark 15 jahre
lang reale zuwächse 15 jahre lang
relativ hohe stabilität und 15 jahre in
denen die schere bei den einkommen
anders als es oft falsch behauptet wird
nicht auseinander gegangen ist sie haben
sie da auch gewaltig gestiegen zum
beispiel der sich wohnungs bereichen
klar reich aber auch da auch da gilt in
den 60er jahren haben die leute mehr und
in den 70er jahren haben die leute von
ihrem verfügbaren netto mehr fürs wohnen
ausgegeben und mehr auch für die
lebensmittel vielleicht weniger für
urlaub für computer und für andere dinge
die man heute braucht aber
nichtsdestotrotz es gibt umschichtungen
das erste mal dass auch die leute das
machen sie ja auch die geben ja nicht
alle das geld mit vollen händen aus ist
erstmal umgeschichtet wird und da wo es
möglich ist wo reserven und rücklagen
sind man daran geht und der staat eben
nicht in der breite alle mit geld über
überrennt und dass man dann gezielt
schaut wer braucht wirklich aber wichtig
ist einzelfallprüfung das ist bürokratie
das ist mühsam deswegen bin ich auch so
dagegen was die ampel gemacht hat dass
man bei hartz4 die sanktionen und alle
prüfungen aufgegeben hat das ist falsch
das ist die falsche richtung wenn man
gleichzeitig die sätze erhöht und die
prüfungen aufgibt dann schafft man ein
fehlanreiz nämlich genau den weniger zu
tun
die unternehmen haben in den letzten
jahren wirklich ganz ganz schöne gewinne
gemacht auch jetzt in der korona
pandemie wurde kurzarbeitergeld bezahlt
trotzdem wissen wir alle es gibt schon
viele große unternehmen die haben
saubere gewinne gemacht auch die jahre
davor schon auch jetzt gibt's
energieversorger oder unternehmen aus
der chemischen industrie die gerade ein
super geschäftsjahr haben werden
trotzdem interessanterweise sind das die
die jetzt auch dastehen und sagen wir
brauchen eine gasanlage und wir brauchen
staatshilfen damit wir uns die teure
energie leisten können und schon ein
bisschen schwierig wenn man den
privathaushalten sagt ihr müsst jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen sparen also so
ein bisschen porsche ja natürlich erst
jetzt pauschal im ersten unternehmen die
gewinne machen sind wir deshalb nicht
steuerfrei und gewinnen ich muss sagen
auch viele steuer haben zu nehmen die
wenig gewinne machen zahlen wenig
steuern auch die unternehmen des
geholfen worden wo sie hatten in der
pandemien auch eine menge problem ist ja
auch nicht so dass finde dass alles so
weiter gegangen werden
und ehrlich unter gewinne gemacht es gab
selbstständigen die mussten aufgeben
also das ist mir ein bisschen zu
pauschal und wir nebenher als vater
dieser panikmache ich muss aus seiner
gewinne mittlerweile den eindruck dass
immer wieder in jeder neuen runde wird
immer neu entlastung gefordert die
politiker überbieten sich mit
überlastung angeboten und ich habe das
jetzt mal ganz kurz mitgebracht was ist
schon alles gibt kinderbonus kinder
sofort zuschlag einmalzahlungen der
grundsicherung einmalzahlung für
empfänger von arbeitslosengeld
heizkostenzuschuss abschaffen der eeg
energie post pauschale
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag grund also die
ganze liste ist es der die liste der
regierung da kann man fünf minuten
vorlesen was ich schon an hilfen gibt
gesamtsumme bis jetzt 30 milliarden euro
und ob da kann man jetzt nicht so tun
als wenn gar nichts passierte das heißt
nicht dass man den bedürftigen die sie
eben auch zumal genannt haben ihrem
stadtteil kennen wir das vorstellen dass
man den hilft ja aber jetzt so zu tun
als sei er noch gar nichts passiert man
müsse jetzt endlich mal etwas wichtiges
wie es dann heißt machen das ist glaube
ich etwas falsches kolorierung wirklich
der rechtsrahmen eine zweitfassung
paketen die zeugnisse auf deswegen habe
ich bin gespannt was das dritte bringt
aber aus dem realen leben
wenn ich nur ein beispiel nehme aus
neukölln die tee und wärmestube neukölln
wird ziemlich gestützt durch sponsoren
aus der mittelschicht also restaurants
supermärkte alles möglich das ist uns
alles weggebrochen das ist nur in der
korona zeitlicher weggebrochen wir haben
also zwei fürchterliche jahre schon
hinter uns wo wir das gemerkt haben was
da eigentlich auch in zukunft und jetzt
kommt die nächste runde so und wenn
jetzt auch dann der krieg ist ja noch
dazugekommen am 24 februar gegen die
ukraine so dann einen tag später war das
erledigt dann haben wir einbrüche gehabt
von 90% im spendenaufkommen wir leben
nun mal davon wir leben davon dass die
obdachlose wohnungslosenhilfe
nahrungsmittel ist nicht im budget drin
durch den senat und auch nicht durch den
bezirk sondern das ist alles schon
vorher bleibt bei den lebensmitteln sie
bemängelt etagen tun das auch
immer weniger spenden woran liegt das
eigentlich dass ich das hängt denn dass
wir weniger übrig bleibt dass weniger
lebensmittel verschwörung stadt den
titel hat zum beispiel also wenn ich es
nennen darf hat sie drei euro paket
geschnürt was dann am ende des tages
verkauft wird das fehlt uns natürlich
den tafeln übrigens auch und die tafeln
haben ja zu wechsel von 1,8 millionen
mittlerweile das kommt ja nicht von
ungefähr das ist doch keine einzelfälle
mehr so und wenn ich unsere rentner
anschaue oder unser bedürftigen die
rennen überall rum und suchen
nahrungsmittel es gibt nichts mehr also
sind nur noch die sozialträger also wie
das die caritas das diakonische werk
diesen noch vorhanden und versuchen das
abzufangen da die auch nicht im budget
sind wir müssen jetzt alles drauf haben
alle hast ja das ja aber die kriegen
keine weil wir 60 prozent osteuropäische
menschen haben die im nicht anspruch
haben und das ist das problem das wird
immer so dargestellt also wenn das jetzt
das sind alles jetzt leute die alle
march 4 oder einer grundsicherung sind
sind sie nicht wir haben 60 prozent und
das ist richtig viel und die müssen wir
versorgen und ich müsste ja
kein menschenleben darf weggeworfen
werden nur weil es gerade
weiß nicht passt jeder mensch muss
mitgenommen werden und dafür müssen wir
sorgen wie die politik das dann im
endeffekt macht das müssen wir dann
sehen aber wir warten auf das dritte
entlastungspaket und wie gesagt
obdachlosen und wohnungslosenhilfe ist
nicht dabei
das sind die träger die gestützt werden
müssen die erfüllen staatsaufgaben das
ist einfach so das hat nichts damit zu
tun dass gerade im hartz-iv-bereich oder
grundsicherung dass sie einigermaßen
über die runden kommen schaffen diese
aber auch teilweise nicht mehr ja aber
bei den tafeln wie viele menschen sind
bei den tafeln 1,8 mio wie in welcher
altersgruppe haben wird hier und das ist
das interessante dass die alters große
gruppe sich total verschiebt von 60 auf
80 und das ist meiner ansicht nach schon
furchtbar wenn der 80 jährige frau an
der tafel steht und nahrungsmittel
möchte weil sie sich im grunde boden
schämt zum jobcenter zu gehen und geld
zu behindern das ist einfach so wir
haben einfach gar nicht mehr die
kapazitäten aller abzufangen und dann
isolieren die leute sich so wie dieses
paar corona gemacht wenn wir isolieren
sie in ihrer wohnung wir haben kein wir
wissen nicht mehr wo sie sind wenn wir
nicht zufällig die leuten kennen oder
deswegen müssen wir auch die
seniorenbeiräte die den kiezen sind also
bzw in den bezirken die müssen gestützt
werden sie müssen oft finanziell
gestützt werden dass die seniorenbeiräte
die wissen wo ihre leute sind aber das
schaffen die auch nicht mehr alles
ehrenamt ist jetzt ganze land lebt vom
ehrenamt wir haben 17 917 millionen
ehrenamtliche es
durch die durchweg ein lebendes tier
angegriffen werden wir müssen gucken
dass wir alle mitnehmen und wir haben
auch ukrainischer geflüchtete die zu den
tafeln ging es dürfen auch nicht
vergessen das ist eine ganz tolle sache
war sein problem ist in berlin wir reden
mal
anders sein oder in frankfurt am main
aber in berlin ist es nun mal so in den
berner dürfen wir keinen verlieren
natürlich das ist auch alles sehr
sympathisch was sie sagen aber schauen
sie mal wir haben im prinzip die
sozialleistungsquote in deutschland von
30 prozent wir sind damit in der eu bei
den 27 ländern an vierter stelle wir
haben sieben millionen menschen die
sozusagen
leistung bekommen zurzeit wird also es
ist ja nicht so als wenn der staat
nichts tun würde das habe ich nicht
gesagt na ja gut aber wir müssen doch
irgendwo auch mal sehen dass der anteil
des des so der sozial etats auch immer
größer dafür hatte auch was geleistet
darüber rede ich doch gern darüber es
geht ja nicht darum dass nichts
geleistet wird die frage ist kann man
denn den anteil der sozialleistungen am
staatsbudget immer weiter immer weiter
ausbauen und ich habe wie gesagt den
eindruck auch jetzt angesichts der
energiekrise und angesichts diverser
anderer krisen dass die politiker aus
angst vor dem wähler immer mehr in immer
mehr versprechen und die frage ist am
ende wer bezahlt hast gibt es
fehlanreize werden dinge mit der
gießkanne ausgegossen vielleicht an
leute die es gar nicht brauchen dass die
armut in diesem land da ist dass sie
erschreckend ist und das anders
natürlich auch trifft und fallen wenn
man wie sie der arbeitet das ist völlig
klar ist bestreitet doch niemand die
frage ist aber was ist die politische
kunst aber die ihre version
genau das auszudiskutieren sie sagen
immer man dafür nicht so tun als gäbe es
keine entlastung machen wir alle nicht
aber für mich ist genau das ja der sinn
hier gerade dass hier verschiedene ideen
versucht werden unter einen hut zu
bringen das versucht die ampel natürlich
noch mal ganz anders aber wie hier auch
gerade weil wir alle ein stück weit
recht auch eine unterschiedliche
sichtweise auf die dinge haben zu mir
kommen natürlich nicht die menschen und
zu ihnen auch nicht die gerade sagen ja
klar ist ein bisschen ärgerlich wenn
jetzt die tomaten mehrkosten oder wenn
ich fürs gas vielleicht ein doppelt oder
dreifach so berechnungen habe die
menschen gibt es bei uns und das ist
auch okay wenn die das nicht so arg
stört aber bei uns gibt es eben immer
mehr menschen für die das wirklich ein
problem ist auch für die sogenannte
mittelschicht das war vorher um genau
das vermischt sich eben jetzt immer mehr
dass wir uns nicht mehr so ganz klar
trennen kann das gibt die mittelschicht
das ganz okay geht und es gibt die
menschen die sozialleistung brauchen und
die eben nicht mehr klarkommen ich
glaube das wirklich immer mehr ein
problem wird dass es heute für viele
menschen eben weil sie vielleicht nicht
ganz so gute löhne haben weil sie
vielleicht nur teilzeit arbeiten können
dass es für diese menschen auch wirklich
immer schwieriger wird mit den hohen
kosten zu leben und da sich gedanken zu
machen finde ich richtig und auch nicht
natürlich ist das ausweiten des
wohngelds von olaf scholz vorgeschlagen
ist eine maßnahme über die man sich
reden kann auch für mich ist das nicht
die einzig super maßnahme wenn man den
sozialleistungen ausweiten weil wir aus
unserer wartung vor allem wissen ist
wollen gar nicht die menschen nur
sozialleistungen haben den menschen wer
sich eine höhere rente sie hätten
bessere löhne und bräuchten nicht zum
beispiel mit 34 kinder noch aufstocken
das co2 und habe das was ich was sie
haben
wir eben nicht alles gleichzeitig
abfedern können sozial weil nicht
genügend geld da ist alle wünsche zu
erfüllen müsste man nicht auch eine
priorisierung vornehmen dann sagt also
wichtig ist eine energie pauschale
wichtig ist wohngeld wichtig ist
heizkostenzuschuss wichtig sind die
ganzen transferleistungen die kinder
betreffen minderjährige kinder dass man
sagt das sind jetzt die wichtigen sachen
und die frage ob das neue euro ticket
weitergeführt wird das stellen wir ein
bisschen zurück das ist ja auch
möglicherweise sehr kostenintensiv
sondern sagt dass man jetzt erst mal
kritisiert welche leistungen sind am
wichtigsten die kommen jetzt auch ins
nächste entlastungspaket also die
sogenannten daseinsvorsorge eben wohnen
heizen
lebensmittel ist natürlich sicherlich
die prio 1 ich würde mich natürlich
schon ein bisschen schwer tun mich
hinzusetzen und zu sagen so was wie ein
teil habe eine mobilität ist komplett
unwichtig machen sie auch mit äußerungen
gegen den ich frei sagt ja nur ich würde
mich jetzt einfach ein bisschen schwer
tun zu sagen was genau alles in die prio
1 gruppe gehört bei den von mir
genannten dinge ist es klar dass ein
dach über dem kopf heizung essen
kleidung das ist das
gesundheitsversorgung klar das sind die
wirklich super wichtigen dinge aber wir
haben ja gerade auch wirklich beim neuen
euro ticket und anderen maßnahmen jetzt
gesehen dass es schon für die menschen
natürlich auch etwas gutes und wichtiges
ist sich eben bewegen zu können
auch für studierende zum beispiel die
jetzt
ja mal wieder was sich vielleicht ein
bisschen weiter fahren können oder
familien war das schon eine gute sache
aber natürlich würde ich auch immer
sagen die sogenannte daseinsvorsorge
existenzsicherung hat natürlich immer 31
aber weil sie gerade auch in ihrer
fragestellung so gesagt haben das ist
nicht genug geld da ist ja schon ein
bisschen eine frage wie das geld
verteilt ist ist nicht genug geld da
natürlich ist es nicht der weisheit
letzter schluss die sozialausgaben immer
hoch zu fahren und nichts an den
einnahmen zu machen den punkt sehe ich
schon auch und einnahmen werden eben
durch steuern generiert an der
einkommenssteuer wird es nicht zu machen
sein aber es gibt schon noch andere
punkte wie eine finanztransaktionssteuer
im biene vermögenssteuer besteuerung die
nicht zweifelsohne nicht ganz einfach
ist das kommt sonst jetzt gleich ich sag
schon selber hinter runde das ist nicht
einfach ist ganz
den punkt schon selber abgeräumt habe
ich den herren jetzt erspart aber es
gibt möglichkeiten
aber wichtig ist einfach an der eine
kann man noch was tun wie gesagt ich war
vor ein paar wochen in der talkrunde mit
einem firmenchefin denn hier keine namen
der hat konnte uns gar nicht sagen wie
viele milliarden es gerade geht in
seinem geschäftsjahr und da da ist schon
noch was zu machen gut die einzelnen die
einzelfälle gibt es immer dass ein paar
auch nicht wissen wohin mit dem geld das
mag sein dass spricht sich auch gerne
schnell rum und kommt in die medien aber
wir haben in deutschland schon die
höchste steuerquote die wir je hatten
also die steuerlast ist über die jahre
drastisch angewachsen auch ohne formale
steuererhöhungen wo wirklich
steuererhöhungen etwas bringen ist bei
der genau dem was die kleinen leute am
meisten trifft was man nicht will
nämlich bei der mehrwertsteuer das
bringt ein einziger punkt 14 milliarden
das bringt richtig was viel mehr als
diese ganzes ganze gerede über
reichensteuer spitzensteuersatz und
vieles mehr das wollen wir auch nicht
insofern müssen wir schon priorisieren
und mir wäre es auch lieber bei all den
detaildiskussionen es gibt diese vielen
betroffenen fälle und da müssen wir auch
wirklich was tun aber wir diskutieren
jetzt immer die folgen der inflation die
wirkungen und legen dann einzelne
pflaster und verbände auf unterstadt
geriert sich dabei als retter der staat
ist aber zugleich mittäter bei der
inflation ist zugleich nutzen ließ dabei
seine staatsschulden dadurch entwertet
werde also sprich diejenigen die jetzt
vor geben uns zu helfen hektisch auch
zum teil wegen der landtagswahl in
niedersachsen deswegen muss jetzt auch
plötzlich was für die rentner passieren
weil die die wählermehrheit stellen die
über 55-jährigen dieser staat lässt
zugleich in europa und damit sind wir
beim wirklichen gegner ein stück weit
lässt in europa auch die dinge laufen
und schludern und deswegen wäre es mir
auch lieb wenn all diejenigen die in
deutschland immer mit vielen gut
gemeinten und guten gründen frisches
geld und neue ausgaben und hilfen
fordern dann auch mal zu frau lagarde
bei der ezb und zum bundeskanzler rennen
und sagen so was tut ihr eigentlich auf
europäischer ebene damit die
geldwertstabilität erhalten bleibt den
inflation trifft am meisten die kleine
leute trifft die sparer trifft die
vorsorgenden inflation macht alles und
macht zukunft kaputt und deswegen ist
das wichtigste jetzt prio 1 nicht nur
die folgewirkungen zu lindern mit
einzelnen maßnahmen sondern die
inflation trifft alle trio 1 ist die
inflation zu bekämpfen und endlich mal
in diesem frankfurter hochhaus ein
bisschen kreative unruhe zu verbreiten
und endlich in europa mal dieses thema
zu diskutieren
ja aber sie haben hier heute gebracht
mit 7,9 bestimmbar und jetzt das heute
schon die meldung ausgegangen wir
erwarten zehn prozent also es geht jeden
tag wird irgendwas durchs dorf gejagt
und das ist das problem und diese
irritationen die wir ständig haben weil
die leute so wahnsinnige angst und
nervöse die haben wirklich sorgen bei
jedem tag kommt aller jede stunde kommt
eine neue meldung was alles passiert was
teurer wird 1000 prozent der energie die
deutsche wohnen die hat noch 1
reingehauen mit 31 prozent mieterhöhung
also das sind alles die leute werden
verrückt dass ich noch mal heim schützen
oder gehen einfach etwas jetzt auf die
europäische zentralbank ja eigentlich da
die zinserhöhung ist und die inflation
zu dämpfen da sind aber länder wie
italien und spanien vor weil die würden
nämlich unter diesen bedingungen
möglicherweise von ihren eigenen
staatsschulden abgemurkst werden ist das
wirklich so
leicht zu händeln oder so wie wir uns
das jetzt vielleicht wünschen um in
deutschland die inflation zu dämpfen man
hat bisher nicht den mut gehabt die
diskussion auf europäischer ebene
ehrlich zu führen und ein harmonisches
freundliches gipfelfoto war bei jedem
eu-gipfel noch wichtiger als eine
ehrliche diskussion
faktisch ist es so dass die deutschen
sparer und vorsorgenden ein relatives
finanzpolitisches laissez faire in
italien mitfinanzieren und das führt bei
uns jetzt zur inflation oder trägt einen
beigen hier ja jemanden mit engem basis
kontakt der spd-chef läuft gegen weil
hat gesagt es könnte in dieser
gesellschaft etwas brandgefährliches für
die gesellschaft und auch für die
demokratie und wachsen also politische
instabilität wie ist denn die stimmung
bei den menschen in der umgebung der sie
sich bewegen wo viele menschen sich
sozial und material beton also ich weiß
dass herr klicken weil das gesagt das
hat aber annalena baerbock auch schon
gesagt vor monaten schon nämlich alles
soll ich kann es jetzt ziemlich genau
zeitgleich festlegen vor zwei monaten
oder vor einem monat hat sich so etwas
ähnliches gesagt dass wir hier gefahr
laufen das aufstellen der kommen und
alles will also diesen brandherd
das habe ich nicht das muss ich so sagen
das habe ich in dieser form nicht also
man schimpft logisch aber man geht nicht
nur schritt weiter dass unser demokratie
ein existenzielles problem hat das
glaube ich schon wenn das so weitergeht
wenn die leute jeden tag verrückter
gemacht werden irgendwann kommen die
richtigen oder die falschen auf die edi
umbringt dann irgendetwas da was was wir
eigentlich nicht wollen die politik muss
dafür sorgen dass ruhe einkehrt wieder
und das ganz klare aussagen getroffen
werden und wir haben da corona politik
ich habe immer wieder gesagt der hai
wieder hat jeden tag eine
pressekonferenz gegeben jeden tag und
das volk hat zugehört ob sie das nun
wollten oder nicht aber sie haben
zugehört und das brauchen wir auch vom
bundeskanzler der bundeskanzlerin bis
ich wirklich alles nach hinstellt und
sagt so passt das sind die dinge die wir
jetzt vorgeschlagen die werden
durchgeführt und damit es gut nicht das
von rechts und links schon wieder andere
mitteilungen kommen das macht ja die
leute so wahnsinnig aber es ist ja auch
ein bisschen schwierig wenn der
bundeskanzler hat es so schön deutschen
satz geprägt nur never walk alone also
das ist nicht alleine gearbeitet aber
das reichte nicht und ist auch keine
politik sich vor eine kamera zu stellen
zu sagen you never walk alone bist du
dass du wirst nicht alleine gelassen man
dessen aus so pauschal versprechen die
sind meiner meinung nach genauso
verantwortungslos die das schüren von
ängsten oder das herbeireden von
sozialen aufständen in meine frau brooke
hat das gesagt
herr klingbeil hat das gesagt ich finde
das ist kein zeichen verantwortlicher
politik wenn man aufstände herbeiredet
also jetzt auch mal registergericht soll
ja also das ist auch geld also das
ersetzt auch keine politik man muss eben
auch mal sehen herford hat es gesagt wir
haben anfang oktober die wahl in den
niedersachsen wer fordert jetzt die
aufhebung der schuldenbremse
auch für das nächste jahr der
niedersächsische ministerpräsident
stephan weil weil er mit blick auf die
umfragen natürlich befürchten muss dass
die schlechte aufführung seiner
parteikollegen ihr in berlin auch seine
wiederwahl gefährden könnte und das ist
eben auch ein teil der wahrheit dass
ebene der takt der versprechungen der
pauschalen
behauptungen was alles gemacht werden
müsste was noch kommen soll wie
gefährlich das alles ist das natürlich
der tatsache geschuldet dass die
regierenden parteien angst vor den
wählern haben die merken dass das was da
gerade läuft offenbar nicht so gut ist
da sehen wirklich hilft und dass dabei
sich die katze in den schwanz ich meine
das ist den wir uns einig das ist der
stil der populismus der am ende auch
keinen hilfe der aber am ende zu
versprechen führt die wirklich auch erst
mal bezahlt werden müssen wir haben in
wenigen jahren fehlen am arbeitsmarkt 4
millionen leute die gehen alle in rente
das sind die ganzen leute aus der baby
boomer generation ist 1 4 millionen gut
ausgebildete heute arbeitenden menschen
sagt essens wollen die eine rente haben
die nicht gering ist zweitens müssen die
ersetzt werden und wir haben heute schon
einen riesigen fachkräftemangel und dann
muss das ja alles bezahlt werden wenn
die rentenversicherung ist der größte
zuschuss fall in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik jeder dritte
steuereinnahmen jeder dritte euro der
steuern geht als zuschuss in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung so dann
sagen sie natürlich es gibt viele
rentner in diesen armen das stimmt es
ist immer schwierig diese fälle zu sehen
wie sie in ihrer täglichen praxis diese
betroffenheit auch zu spüren dass das
was nehme ich ihnen auch alles ab aber
wir kommen auch nicht an der an der
tatsache vorbei dass wir den zuschuss
zur rentenversicherung halt immer mehr
steigern und irgendwo kommt man dann
auch an ein verhältnis frage dass man
sagt müssen wir denn es jeden zweiten
euro den wir einnehmen von den steuern
als zuschuss für die rentenversicherung
geben und müssen wir den sozialetat der
dann auch schon viele milliarden noch
mal zusätzlich aufstoßen also wir müssen
auch mal ein bisschen darüber reden wie
wir die dinge vernünftig verteilen und
das irgendwo auch mal bei den ganzen
versprechen und bei den bei den in
aussicht gestellten wohltaten zur
sicherung von wiederwahlen irgendwann
auch mal ein limit gibt wir haben
nächstes jahr die schuldenbremse
vereinbart wenn die jetzt wieder gekippt
werden soll und wieder neue schulden
gemacht werden soll die irgendwann
abgetragen werden nicht von ihnen oder
von mir sondern von unseren kindern von
den kämpfern den leuten danach geboren
werden die aber leider immer weniger
wenn wie soll das gehen das ist auch
keine verantwortliche politik
der olaf scholz der bundeskanzler ist ja
sicherlich auch ein getriebener durch
externe faktoren aber eben auch durch
eigene ansprüche und auch seine eigenen
machtsicherung er soll jetzt dieses
entlastungspaket sollen jetzt möglichst
schnell kommen diese oder spätestens
nächste woche
da ist man sich überhaupt nicht einig
auch das haben wir ja hier
diskussionen gemerkt da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche interessen in den
parteien
da werden die fetzen fliegen
ist das aber was kommt dabei raus aber
man kann jetzt sagen wir ja zwei monate
zweiter kann man sich zweimonatlich
klausur nach meseberg zurückziehen das
wird nicht funktionieren dass das was
ist jetzt zu erwarten was erwarten sie
es wird ein kompromiss geben vermutlich
bei der frage der der finanzierung
dieses dritten entlastungspaket erlitten
hatte schon so ein signal gegeben
aber die glaubt die große
belastungsprobe für die koalition wird
sein wenn eben immer mehr geld gebraucht
wird und auch gefordert wird von der spd
von den grünen was geschieht dann mit
der schuldenbremse so und die
forderungen die man das fing jahren vor
ein paar wochen schon da kam als man die
spd-linken in der bundestagsfraktion und
forderten das dann kam paar grüne jetzt
kommt herr weil schon also man merkt
auch die die prominenz der leute die das
fordern steigt irgendwann
werden die zylinder gehen sagen so das
tut uns leid christian dann müssen es
halt doch mal die schuldenbremse
zurücknehmen und dann bin ich gespannt
was er machen wird er hat ein großes
problem weil die fdp ist in dieser
regierung zwischen zwei linken partei
eingeklemmt ihre rolle ist die
finanzpolitischen stabilität so wenn sie
das aber nicht leisten kann weil sie
dann doch noch neue schulden machen muss
dann bekommen sie ein problem und wir
werden das morgen in der phoenix runde
genau mit dieser frage der koalition
befassen was da passiert wenn eleganz
kurz-einsatz wir sind wirklich am ende
der sendung glauben sie dass das
leistungspaket das jetzt kommt sie
einigermaßen zufrieden stellen könnte
oder sind sie daher haben sie wenig
hoffnung ach ich bin vom team optimismus
da wird sicherlich was ganz gut aus
dabei sein aber solange wir keine
details wissen und so lange bin ich
wirklich mal an die vermögen zur
verteilung ihrem land rangehen wird das
immer schwierig seien und deswegen bin
ich einfach mal gespannt gut ich bedanke
mich dass sie da waren berliner pendele
michael heil fortan im kopf hat und
thomas dem wahren liebe zu schauen ich
habs gerade schon gesagt morgen der
phoenix runde krach oder kuschelkurs die
koalition in schweren zeiten
weiteres und aktuell ist bei phoenix der
tag mit maria weber darin unter anderem
eine pressekonferenz des adac denn heute
sind auf jeden fall tank rabatt und
zunächst auch mal dass neun euro gibt
geschichte bleiben sie bei uns